- Je vais vous demander
de circuler,rcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcr.
- Une visite présidentielle
comporte son lot de défis
organisationnels.
(propoPour ces résidents du Pas-
Calais, cette visite d'Emmanuel
Macron est source d'intérêt.
Certains se sont présentés
- C'est relativement rare
que le président se déplace,
quand même. Donc, c'est pour ça
qu'on est venus.
politiques à partager.
- Il y a eu les lois sanrereres,
les lois liberticides.
Donc, on est aussi
- Ce jour-là, le président
s'arrêananans une ville marquée
par son passé minier.
La semaine précédente,
une région rurale à environ
600 km plus au sud.
Peu importe la destination, ils
sont nombreux, élus ou citoyens,
à se posecececececececececececes
représentez aux élection
(rires)
La question...
- Moi, je... En temps voulu,
j'annoncerai ma décision.AEAEAË,
corresp. de Radio-Canada à Paris
- Si Emmanuel Macron n'a
toujours pas confirmé qu'il
se pson entourage s'active déjà.
Le président a recueilli
de nombreux parrainages d'élus
locaux essentiels pour confirmer
politique a même lancé
un site de campagne.
Attendre le plus possible avant
de se lancer dans la mêlée,
maintes fois utilisée.
- Oui, je suis candida
- Jacques Chirac et Nicolas
Sarkozy ont tous deux fait leur
- Oui, je suis candidat
à l'électidididididentielle.
- François Mitterrand avait même
attendu jusqu'au 22 mars 1988,
tour de la présidentielle.
- Êtes-vous à nouveau candidat à
- Oui.
- Les présidtatatatatants
croient que leur poste leur
confère une position de force.
THOMAS LEGRAND, éditorialiste
politincncncncnce Inter
- Il préfère rester celui
qui gère ça avec une imageeeeeee
celui qui va dans la bataille,a.
- Pandémie, crise à la frontière
présidence française du conseil
de l'Union européenne,
pas à rappeler qu'il a
de grands dossiers à gérer.
Mais attention, dit cet
analyste, il fau
son bilan. La fonction vient
donc avec son lot
d'inconvénients.
une oppositionririririririté.
Il y a une majorité et beaucoup
Emmanuel Macron qui est central.
Tout le monde se coalise contre
lui. Donc, les critiques fusent,
un avantage.
- Les visites et les annonces
d'investissement sont-elles
celles d'un chobobobobobobobobo?
Certains ne s'en formalisent
pas.
SAMIA SADOUNE,
mairOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOt
de la République comme on doit
l'accueillir en tant que
républicains. Donc, nous l'avons
c'est toujours important
de s'entendre annoncer
des moyens pour pouvoir
continuer la rénovation
- Mais d'autres, comme cet élu
du Rassemblement Natio
croient que l'ambiguïté
doit cesser.
national des Hauts-de-France
- Ça pose parararararararce que
du moment où on est candidat,
- ♪ Même si Macron
nous, on est là ♪
- Ce suspense, qui n'en est
ne pourra pas s'éterniser.
Les candidats à
ont jusqu'au 4 mars pour
confirmer leur volon